[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
coup d'envoi de davos le forum
économique mondial a démarré avec
quelques mois de retard en raison du coc
vide 19 l'ukraine est à l'honneur dans
les alpes suisses volodymyr et lens qui
a fait le premier discours ce matin le
président ukrainien demande plus d'armes
et des sanctions maximum at il dit
contre moscou avec un arrêt complet du
commerce avec la russie impact direct du
conflit et dont on parle beaucoup à
davos et bien sûr la flambée des prix
alimentaires
alors quels sont les risques de famine
notamment en afrique avec la guerre en
ukraine et la crise du coc vie de la
mondialisation telle que nous l'avons
connu ces trente dernières années est
elle terminée
régionalisation en renationalisation
démondialisation ont-ils le vent en
poupe vers une crise alimentaire
mondiale la guerre en ukraine au coeur
de davos on en débat avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir mes côtés jean
françois loiseau bonsoir président adac
céréales alors axéréal c'est une
coopérative agricole et agroalimentaire
qui collectent et qui commercialise des
céréales bienvenue à vous en face de
vous benjamin coriat bonsoir économiste
et membre des économistes atterrés
hauteur de le bien commun le climat et
le marché réponse à jean tirole rien que
ça c'est aux liens qui libèrent
bienvenus benjamin avec nous donc en
duplex de beyrouth bonsoir à vous karim
emile bitar
directeur de sciences po directeur de
sciences-po beyrouth à l'université
saint-joseph bienvenue à vous nous avons
duplex de davos notre envoyé spécial
ligne rifai ligne journaliste économique
france 24 bonsoir à vous line
bonsoir stéphanie avant de démarrer ce
débat on va écouter tout de suite
volodymyr et lens qui s'était donc pour
ouvrir justement les débats à davos ce
matin
pour vêtements
toutes formes de commerce avec la russie
doit être interrompu il faut atteindre
un niveau de dissuasion convaincant qui
pourra servir de dissuasion pour l'été
enia venir
il faut créer un précédent il faut que
toutes les entreprises étrangères se
retire totalement du marché russe pour
que vos marques ne soient pas associés à
des crimes de guerre pour que votre
production ne soit pas utilisée par ces
criminels de guerre
tout de suite justement on retrouve line
rifaï à davos line on peut dire que
l'ukraine est à l'honneur on l'a vu avec
ce discours de volodymyr hélas qui en
plus il faut noter l'absence des russes
il n'y a pas un seul oligarques à davos
cette année alors qu'ils sont très
souvent sponsor de davos davos
s'engagent vraiment du côté des
ukrainiens
oui en effet absence de la russie
présence très importante de l'ukraine
cette année à davos alors les
responsables les organisateurs du forum
économique mondial n'ont pas voulu qu'il
y ait de présence que cette année ils
ont exclu les russes de l'organisation
de ce forum économique mondial c'est la
première fois que cela arrive depuis la
chute de l'union soviétique et même la
maison de la russie la chine la hausse
ici à davos a été donc reprise apparaît
l'oligarque ukrainien qui l'a rebaptisé
winehouse et ils sont exposés donc des
photographies de la guerre en ukraine et
puis concernant donc le soutient
l'engagement de davos à l'ukraine on l'a
vu au tout début de ce forum économique
mondial le fondateur du forum klaus
schwab qui lance qui présente le
président le président écrit ukrainien
volodimir zelensky qui loue son
leadership et qui lui dit dites nous
comment vous aider alors le président
ukrainien il a saisi cette main tendue
et dans le discours qu'il a fait par
visioconférence il a fait un appel à
l'élite politique économique présente
ici à davos pour une aide sur le plan
militaire plus d'envoi dame une aide sur
le plan politique davantage de sanctions
contre la russie un embargo sur le
pétrole russe plus de fermeté vis-à-vis
de là aussi et puis il a demandé aussi
une aide sur le plan économique et
financier il a notamment souligné que
l'ukraine avait besoin sur le 8 2 5
milliards de dollars par mois pour faire
face aux conséquences de la guerre il a
ensuite appelé le secteur privé les
patrons d'entreprises de multinationales
présents ici à davos les a appelés à
quitter la russie à ne plus commercer
avec la russie et à venir plus tôt en
ukraine à investir massivement en
ukraine pour la reconstruction du pays
il est bien sûr question également de la
crise alimentaire mondiale dont on va
beaucoup parler dans cette émission all
in justement à davos conséquence de la
guerre en ukraine
oui la crise alimentaire mondiale
stéphanie c'est l'une des conséquences
de la guerre en ukraine alors l'ukraine
avant la guerre était l'un des
principaux producteurs et exportateurs
de céréales notamment de blé et de maïs
un des principaux producteurs
exportateurs aussi d'huile végétale en
particulier de l'huile de tournesol
toutes ses exportations elles se sont
arrêtées avec la guerre en ukraine les
prix des matières premières alimentaires
ont flambé est ce qui accroît encore
cette flambée des prix c'est que
d'autres pays producteurs vers qui donc
les importateurs pourrait se tourner par
exemple l'inde pour le blé par exemple
aussi l'indonésie pour l'huile de palme
on utilise parfois comme substitut à
l'huile de tournesol et bien ces pays
ont tout simplement décidé de stopper
leurs exportations pour assurer d'abord
leur propre sécurité alimentaire cela
fait flamber davantage les prix des
matières premières agricoles à travers
le monde cela inquiète et notamment la
directrice générale du fonds monétaire
internationale kristalina georgieva
s'exprimer sur le sujet tout à l'heure
au cours d'une table ronde sur les
questions d'inflation et sécurité
alimentaire
elle a dit on peut faire face à la crise
énergétique les pays peuvent à la
rigueur limiter leur consommation
d'énergie en revanche il n'est pas
possible de limiter la consommation
d'aliments c'est un besoin essentiel il
faut donc agir pour faire face à cette
crise alimentaire et puis les
responsables ukrainiens ils ont bien
compris l'importance stratégique de leur
pays j'ai assisté en
une conférence donnée hier par plusieurs
membres du parlement ukrainien
cinq femmes elles ont dit clairement que
leur pays joue un rôle stratégique y
avait aussi près de 40 millions de
tonnes de céréales dans le pays qui
n'attendaient qu'à être exportées et que
pour cela il suffisait selon elle que la
guerre ça aide que l'ukraine gagne la
guerre pour résoudre toujours selon elle
le problème de sécurité alimentaire
dispose une manière de réclamer aussi de
demander le soutien de la communauté
internationale
on va y revenir line karim emile bitar
vous êtes donc à beyrouth un vous la
guerre en ukraine celle ondes de chocs
géopolitiques qui déstabilisent les
marchés mondiaux de l'énergie et de
l'alimentation on peut dire qu'au liban
la crise alimentaire est bien réelle
absolument nous avons découvert avec
stupéfaction que le liban était de tous
les pays du monde arable plus
vulnérables à cette guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine pas moins de 96 % de
nos importations de blé proviennent de
ces deux pays donc le liban est encore
plus vulnérable que le soudan où ces 90%
records plus vulnérables que l'egypte et
la tunisie donc ce qui me frappe
particulièrement c'est précisément ce
que vous avez mentionné en introduction
stéphanie sait les interrogations quant
à l'avenir de la mondialisation
nous sommes dans un paradoxe typique de
notre époque d'un côté notre époque est
marquée par une stupéfiante
interdépendance il n'y a plus de
conflits qui puissent rester circonscrit
nous sommes en présence d'un conflit
mondial quand bien même il ne
s'étendrait pas au delà des frontières
de la russie et de l'ukraine et pourtant
alors même qu'il y à cette
interdépendance il ya des interrogations
quant à savoir si cette mondialisation
et irréversible parce que on a tendance
à penser on a eu tendance à penser ces
trente dernières années que c'était un
acquis que la libre circulation des
biens des marchandises des individus
allait de soi et bien aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que ce n'était pas le cas
cela avait déjà été pointée par certains
politologues il ya dix ans suzanne
berger 2ème haïti avait écrit un livre
sur la première mondialisation entre
1880 et 1914 et à la montre qu'il y
avait eu une première expérience de
mondialisation qui s'était fracassé avec
la montée des nationalismes la première
guerre mondiale et ce n'est qu'en 1981
donc soixante dix ans après la première
guerre mondiale qu'on a retrouvé une
économie mondiale avec le même degré
d'intégration qu'en 1914 donc il est à
craindre aujourd'hui que nous assistions
à une rupture dans cette mondialisation
que nous vivions depuis l'émergence de
l'om sait il ya une quarantaine d'années
on va y revenir karim emile bitar avant
cela jean françois loiseau vous qui a
acheté effectivement et qu'ils
collectaient de l'agroalimentaire qui
commercialisait des céréales avant le
début de l'offensive militaire russe 90%
des exportations de céréales et
d'oléagineux trans transité par les
ports ukrainiens de la mer noire c'est
bien cela c'est une voie aujourd'hui qui
est désormais impraticable c'est ça
d'abord le big bang céréaliers
d'aujourd'hui alors ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que en vingt ans la
russie et l'ukraine sont devenus de très
grands exportateurs de blé tendre des
terres gigantesque une technique qui
s'est fortement développée et comme vous
venez de le dire des infrastructures
ferroviaires fluviales et surtout
portuaire qui se sont énormément
développés avec des investissements
massifs donc il se trouve qu'avec cette
guerre toute la partie occidentale c'est
à dire la partie on va dire plutôt très
ukrainienne était complètement fermée
bush est miné des bateaux sont bombardés
et donc il est impossible de sortir des
céréales il ya quelques bateaux qui
sortent par la mer d'azov mais des
bateaux russes avec des céréales russes
mais je dirais quasiment au compte
gouttes voyez un pays comme l'ukraine
normalement c'est un pays qui sort à peu
près 6 à 6 million et demi de tonnes par
mois et en ce moment c'est plutôt entre
700 millions et 800 mille tonnes par
mois donc il ya une réalité très
concrète non sortie et donc d'un manque
de marchandises sur la scène mondiale la
guerre en ukraine pourrait priver la
planète d'un gisement de 60 millions de
tonnes de céréales benjamin coriat c'est
vrai que c'est énorme
d'où d'ailleurs cette fragilité des pays
du maghreb et d'afrique et du liban
d'ailleurs ben oui c'est à dire qu'il ya
il ya deux phénomènes qui se sont
enchaînés si je peux dire
le coc vide qui a amené une rupture dans
l'est la logistique disons dans les
chaînes d'approvisionnement et beaucoup
de chaos si je peux dire aussi des
raretés 1 puisqu'il ya eu des arrêts de
production etc et puis maintenant c'est
sûr ajoute alors donc la guerre en
ukraine
qui risque alors je suis assez de cet
avis d'avoir des effets de long terme un
parce que c'est plus seulement des
ruptures de logistique de chaîne
d'approvisionnement
cetc des ruptures qui vont avoir des
effets sur ds sur la recomposition des
espaces d'échangés et il ya un certain
nombre de pays qui vont sortir de
l'espace des changes de manière fort
c'est d'abord la russie
de manière pas nécessairement forcé mais
presque par nécessité la chine qui va
beaucoup diminuer son flux des changes
donc on rentre dans une grande période
d'incertitude et sur la question des
céréales que vous connaissez beaucoup
mieux que moi ce que disent les experts
et je parle sous notre contrôle c'est
qu'il ya la crise actuelle et puis il ya
les 12 à 18 mois qui viennent parce que
on plante pas on s'aime pas et on est je
veux dire il n'ya pas plus le problème
aujourd'hui elle risque de durer on va
écouter justement ce qu'en dit
washington washington accuse moscou tout
simplement d'utiliser la nourriture
comme une arme alimentaire on écoute
anthony blinken
la russie affirme à tort que les
sanctions internationales son
responsable de l'aggravation de la crise
alimentaire mondiale
les sanctions ne bloque pas les ports de
la mer noire piégeant des navires plein
de nourriture et ne détruisent pas les
routes et les infrastructures
ferroviaires ukrainienne
c'est la russie les sanctions ne vide
pas les silos à grains craignent un et
ne vole pas le matériel agricole
c'est la russie
non la décision de faire de la
nourriture une arme et celle de moscou
est uniquement de moscou jean françois
loiseau vous diriez cela qu'en fait
c'est une arme aujourd'hui que cette
d'utiliser les céréales comme le fait la
russie c'est une arme alimentaire s'est
totalement une arme alimentaire la
russie est devenue le premier
exportateur de blé la 4e l'ukraine
quatrième exportateur de blé au monde
des potentiel gigantesque
par exemple nous savons que la russie a
au moins volé 400 mille tonnes de blé
dans les derniers jours et c'est de les
vendre par des voix un peu parallèle ou
déguisé bon il se trouve que ces
marchandises avons sur des bateaux les
bateaux vont à destination et les pays
qui vont recevoir ces marchandises vont
être fléché ciblées et mis au banc des
accusés la russie a volé du matériel du
matériel agricole enfin on a vu des
images mais nous nous avons des des
correspondants qui sont sur place et qui
voit quand même ces exactions russes
quasiment quotidiennes donc c'est c'est
plus étonnamment attentionnel ça fait
c'est rare mais c'est totalement
fonctionnel et la crainte que nous avons
elle est double c'est évidemment le prix
des céréales qui augmente et donc
l'alimentation france mais je dirais que
nous avons malheureusement des céréales
cher donc de l'alimentation qui va
monter un peu mais si rien à côté des
pays qui ne vont pas avoir suffisamment
de d'argent pour payer ce blé et il y
aura même passé de disponibilité
monsieur a cité le liban le soudan
pourrait ajouter le mali la tunisie le
maroc l'algérie
je vous en cite 15 comme ça nous allons
vers un risque majeur mondial et c'est
pour ça qu'il ya une une initiative très
forte qui était prise par le président
macron bleus que je trouve très bonne
qui est de 2,2 de nous emmener d'inciter
les entreprises à faire un peu de
solidarité et en même temps du co
développement pour l'afrique parce que
faut régler le sujet à court terme comme
on le disait mais aussi à moyen terme
parce que il ya eu mort vers les
entreprises quand il ya ce type d'appel
vont coopérer oui et nous l'avons vu
avec le co vide un moment donné nous
nous réveillons nous disons mais que
faisons-nous un petit peu de cette
organisation mondiale qui tantôt par le
cos vie tantôt par une guerre
perturbe un peu tous les circuits enfin
aujourd'hui ce que nous vivons c'est
très très grave quand même au delà des
morts et de sept karim et millar vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
jean françois loiseau on est
effectivement dans l'utilisation d'une
arme géopolitique c'est à dire que
finalement la géopolitique s'inscrit
s'invite finalement dans les échanges
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs les pays les
plus dépendants comme le liban où les
pays du moyen-orient les ipte et plus
dépendants ce sont eux évidemment qui en
paye le prix le plus fort
exactement je rejoins tout à fait ce
qu'a dit monsieur l'oiseau bien qu étant
souvent critique de la politique
extérieure des états unis je pense que
monsieur blinken en l'occurrence a tout
à fait raison il ya un débat quant à
savoir si le principal responsable de la
situation actuelle c'est monsieur
poutine qui a envahi l'ukraine ou si ce
sont les sanctions et les pressions
américaines et ça me rappelle la vieille
formule de clemenceau à propos de la
première guerre mondiale qui disait en
tout état de cause ce n'est pas la
belgique qui a envahi l'allemagne donc
là nous sommes dans une situation où il
ya un agresseur très clair qui est la
réussite monsieur poutine monsieur
poutine même une guerre psychologique
multidimensionnelle depuis plusieurs
années déjà et il utilise en effet d'un
côté larmes du viol et de l'autre côté
fêtard me des crises alimentaires et
c'est un chantage permanent à laquelle
auquel il soumet de très nombreux pays
le liban en est un les pays de la corne
de l'afrique vont également être bientôt
toucher à leur tour donc quelles que
soient les réserves que l'on puisse
avoir envers certains aspects des
politiques américaines le principal
responsable de la crise actuelle c'est
monsieur poutine d'autant plus que ceux
qui intervient aujourd'hui n'est pas
tout à fait le timing est
particulièrement frappant parce que déjà
en 2021 avant même cette guerre le
réseau au mondial contre les crises
alimentaires nous parlait d'une
insécurité alimentaire aiguë qui avait
touché en 2021 193 millions de personnes
dans 53 pays on prévoyait une année 2022
qui serait encore plus dur donc la
politique russe aujourd'hui vient
délibérément
accroître ses risques pour des centaines
de millions de personnes à travers la
planète mais jamais encore rien faut-il
pour autant arrêter toutes les
exportations russes donc y compris
céréalière comme le demande zylinski je
dirais aux en prenant le risque
d'aggraver encore ces crises
alimentaires c'est une décision
comment dire qui est à prendre part
c'est une décision géopolitique c'est
pas moi qui vais me prononcer là dessus
par contre ce qui est tout à fait
important de dire dans le prolongement
de ce qui a été dit mais qu'il faut
compléter c'est que avant même le
conflit en ukraine avant avant tout ces
problèmes là il y avait dans le monde et
depuis très longtemps hein ça date pas
de la semaine dernière entre 900
millions et 1 milliard de gens qui sont
sous nourris ou mal nourris donc si ça
prend de telles proportions c'est parce
qu'on est sur une base d'économie
mondiale très très fortement
inégalitaire parce qu'en plus le
problème n'est pas le manque
d'aliments absolue mais la très inégale
répartition à travers la planète alors
sur une situation aussi fragile que
celle là et qui est quand même il faut
il faut le dire organisé par les grandes
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire le
jeu de poutine l'agression est ca a
provoqué des ruptures aux conséquences
catastrophiques
jean françois loiseau alors est-ce que
tout de même il faut arrêter ces
exportations suis désolé de vous reposer
cette question parce que on l'a entendu
volodymyr the lanskies il faut arrêter
tout exportations russes dont qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il faut le faire
même si ça va encore aggraver évidemment
la crise alimentaire une dédiée en
politique mais non il faut pas les
arrêter ses portes et vous donnons par
contre il faut gagner la guerre il faut
gagner la guerre et il faut en même
temps développer des actions parce que
bon bah je vais pas faire le procès des
entreprises agroalimentaires parce que
je crois que nous en avons absolument
besoin ce qu'il faut c'est une des
politiques agricoles et alimentaires
il ya peut-être un problème de
répartition de la nourriture mais il ya
quand même un problème de demande très
forte l'augmentation de la population
mondiale elle est la pierre la chine
l'un d'eux regardez l'afrique qui va
passer de 1 milliard à 1 milliards 2,1
milliards 3 en 20 ans que faisons-nous
demain et donc notre rôle c'est la
question démographique en fait il est
censé aller essentiel et la guerre
montrent que si nous ne faisons rien la
démographie de l'excès de démographie va
exploser et donc nous devons conduire
des politiques de co-développement danse
dans les pays avec lesquels nous devons
travailler moi je pense à l'afrique
principalement et du codéveloppement ça
veut pas dire aller coloniser l'afrique
ça veut dire travailler ensemble il ya
de telles richesses en afrique et je
pense qu'une des portes de sortie et
celle ci ce n'est pas la seule menace
qui lorsqu'il demande effectivement
d'arrêter tout exportations russes
céréalière vous mais je vais vous dire
il est dans son rôle mais on a on n'a
pas interdit l'exportation du gaz russe
ces six joueurs c'est une question il
est question de faire un nombre mais ça
je me permets à part en europe mais je
peux me permettre à lise la principale
voie de sortie pour les céréales russes
c'est la mer noire mais il ya d'autres
sorties il y a le le train qui va vers
kazakhstan en chine il y a les ports
d'exportation vladivostok il y à saint
pétersbourg est donc aujourd'hui il ya
énormément de sorties de céréales russes
et d'oléagineux comme s'était dit tout à
l'heure qui se font soit par la mer de
la mer face à bâté redouble la mer du
nord soit par la chine et la chine
achète beaucoup à la russie donc ne
pensons pas qu'il n'y aura que la la
fermeture de la mer noire qui va régler
tous les programmes efficaces vous dit
si je dis que ce n'est pas du tout assez
efficace faut gagner la guerre il faut
changer le modèle de co développement
notamment avec des dix régions immenses
et moi je pense à l'afrique ça devrait
être notre obsession permanente car
emile bitar voulait peut-être rebondir
sur ce que vient dire jean françois
loiseau vous pensez qu'il faudrait
arrêter toute exportation y compris
céréalière de la russie où ce n'est pas
efficace comme le dit jean fois
soualaise l'oiseau pas assez efficace
trop dangereux trop dangereux
votre réaction votre analyse sa femme au
risque et certains hauts risques et des
pressions sont toutefois nécessaires
mais je pense en tout cas qu'il ya une
priorité aujourd'hui c'est d'éviter la
plus grande crise alimentaire de
l'histoire car cette crise alimentaire
pourrait durer plusieurs années quand
bien même cette guerre prendrait fin
cette crise est venue si vous voulez
jeter une lumière crue sur le fait que
le système alimentaire mondial tout
entier est fragile et je dysfonctionnel
et si l'on n'évolue pas vers de
nouvelles formes d investissements dans
de nouvelles infrastructures dans l'agro
écologie cette crise pourrait perdurer
plusieurs années et si on se place dans
la perspective du temps long écoutez ici
au liban nous apprenez à l'école qu'à
l'époque de l'empiré romain la plaine de
la bekaa près approvisionné en blé tout
l'empiré romain et aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans un pays où cette même
plaine de la bekaa n'exporte qu'un peu
de captagon est un peu de haschich et
nous sommes vulnérables puisque 95 % de
nos exportations viennent de russie et
d'ukraine aujourd'hui le grenier de la
planète c'est la russie et l'ukraine
donc je suis tout à fait d'accord pour
accroître les pressions mais il y a
quand même une urgence c'est celle
d'éviter que cette crise alimentaire ne
devienne la plus grave de l'histoire et
qu'elle ne handicap le développement de
très grand nombre pays en voie de
développement pour les dix prochaines
années jean françois loiseau pour
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire et
expliquer comment on en est arrivé là
est-ce qu effectivement ces pays comme
le liban l'egypte sont devenus
dépendants de la russie et de l'ukraine
parce qu'ils ont pratiqué des prix plus
bas donc c'est devenu avantageux et cet
avantage est devenue une dépendance
c'est comme ça que ça a fonctionné parce
que bon on explique comment on en arrive
là j'ai nommé alors que la plage de la
baie car on le sait effectivement une
prennent mais la fertile aulas dans la
france a été sortie dans sa robe de
marchés du bassin méditerranéen pour des
raisons de prix de de quelques dollars
quelquefois même 2,2 de quelques cents
de la tonne et des pays comme la tunisie
l'egypte et le liban ben moi je sais je
suis allé au liban avec des meuniers
nous avons fait une opération de
solidarité
quand il ya eu l'explosion du site du
fameux stylo de beyrouth je pense que
monsieur sens bien très bien les
meuniers français où emmener 500 tonnes
gratuitement ce ne sont pas les russes
carmine et de la farine ou les
ukrainiens ce sont les français et
encore aujourd'hui on vient nous
chercher en nous disant bombe à
prioriser le liban c'est ce que nous
allons faire la tunisie le liban
l'egypte le maroc et quelques pays
d'afrique mais malheureusement nous
travaillons aussi avec le climat et nous
savons tous que le climat est
essentielle pour beaucoup produire donc
en france le climat depuis 15 jours il
est trop sec et donc on pèse un peu sur
les niveaux de production mais on va y
arriver et puis nous avons besoin de
politiques agricoles de plus en plus dé
carbonée parce que moi j'y suis on va y
revenir mais petit monde mais l'autre
défi qui amène l'alimentation dans tous
les pays avec ce fameux que
développement alors justement parler de
mondialisation le poids ministre indien
mots dinara maudit il avait initialement
assuré que des fermiers indiens
répondrai présent pour nourrir le monde
sait ce qu'il avait dit le 13 mai avant
le 13 mai et le 13 mai et bien l'inde a
annoncé que le pays allait suspendre ses
exportations de blé une décision
qualifiée de dernier domino dans la
désorganisation des circuits
d'approvisionnement c'est une volte face
très importante l'inde a exporté à fait
la même chose d'ailleurs pour les
vaccins elle devait exporter des vaccins
puis soudain face à une crise est bien l
abri des ses exportations line je vous
retrouve à davos la mondialisation telle
qu'on l'a connue finalement pendant ces
30 dernières années et qui était
toujours à l'honneur à davos j'en sais
quelque chose pour faire passer un peu
de temps est-ce que c'est terminé est ce
que c'est ce qu'on dit là-bas
[Musique]
alors on ne dit pas que c'est terminé
mais que ça va se faire de manière
différente c'est ce que c'est ce qui
revient ici à davos mais c'est vrai que
le climat est totalement différent du
dernier forum économique mondial de
davos auquel j'avais assisté c'était en
janvier 2020 la pandémie de kovy de 19
n'avait pas encore vraiment démarré en
tout cas on ne s'attendait pas à une
pandémie au niveau mondial on était
encore un peu dans le monde d'avant on
croyait à la mondialisation heureuse en
tout cas pour certains pour le point les
milieux économiques et à une
mondialisation qui a entraîné des prix
toujours les plus bas et des donc une
production à flux tendu puis il ya eu
cette pandémie de kovy de 19 qui a
surpris aussi tout le monde avec ses
conséquences économiques majeurs c'est
problèmes d'approvisionnement d'abord
pendant la pandémie ensuite dans la
période qui a suivi de reprise
économique mondiale c'est rupture de
chaîne d'approvisionnement est
aujourd'hui davos 2022 davos mais 2022
même puisque l'édition de janvier n'a
pas pu se tenir à bien on se rend compte
qu'on est dans un monde complètement
différent avec ses ruptures de chaîne
d'approvisionnement cette économie à
flux tendu qui ne peut plus marcher
cette fragmentation du processus de
production qui ne peut plus marcher on
se rend compte de cela au niveau
industriel on se rend compte de cela
aussi au niveau de la sécurité
alimentaire et même la directrice
générale du fonds monétaire
international qui souhaite bien sûr
préserver la mondialisation qui souhaite
pas qu'ils aient désagrégation au niveau
mondial elle a quand même eu un regard
critique sur la mondialisation qui a eu
au cours des trente dernières années
elle a dit on a laissé faire cette
mondialisation qui a accru les
inégalités
aujourd'hui il faut accepter une
économie mondialisée où on paye le prix
d'une production parfois plus locale
mais avec une sûreté donc des
approvisionnements avec dont des prix
aussi qu'ils sont plus élevés il faut
payer la sécurité alimentaire il faut
payer la sécurité d'approvisionnement
le mot tel culot on le connaissait avec
des prix bas qui donc frôlé la déflation
et bien ce monde n'est sans doute plus
pour demain en tout cas c'est ce qui se
dit aussi ici à davos benjamin coriat en
train de changer complètement le
logiciel en fait parce qu'à davos était
la mondialisation heureuse alors moi je
vois les termes qui sortent un
aujourd'hui c'est le nearshoring qui
consiste à rapatrier les activités
économiques dans un pays proche de ses
marchés le hall shoring celle inverse du
off shoring c'est à dire on rapatrie là
aussi des activités délocalisées donc le
maître mot aujourd'hui c'est la
relocalisation mais comme le disait line
ça veut dire à des prix plus important
donc il faut renoncer à des prix très
bas dans les produits agricoles et en
même temps rapatrier un petit peu sa
production oui oui c'est ça aujourd'hui
la logique oui oui je pense que je pense
qu'on va dans cette direction
davos et et l'om c'est derrière parce
que d'avoir ça n'est qu'un des lieux
dans lequel s'établissent des consensus
entre puissants 1 pour parler vite mais
bon il n'y a aucun moyen d'action par
contre on avait la machine de guerre
ainsi je peux dire de l'om sait qui a
cassé toutes les barrières partout elle
a pu l'une des derrières des dernières
justement portant sur les services d'un
côté et sur les produits agricoles mais
la sortie aussi 200 millions de chinois
de la pauvreté
et où il a sorti dans ce parc de la
mondialisation libre échange oui
on va faire progressivement le bilan de
la mondialisation c'est sûr que elle a
des effets
paradoxaux d'une certaine manière mais
elle a aussi très largement contribué
sur le sur le plan alimentaire par
exemple un à l'appauvrissement de toute
une série de pays pour lesquels
les prix dans les prix des produits
agricoles à l'arrivée compte tenu des
subventions par exemple européennes
étaient inférieurs aux productions
locales de mil de maïs etc par exemple
en afrique donc je veux dire ça c'est
fini ça s'est fini c'est fini d'abord
pour nous ça veut dire que
obtenir n'importe quel prix au risque de
désertifier et dead le sud de se trouver
en situation de dépendance comme ça a
été le cas sur les produits
de sanitaire et sur les médicaments
pendant le coc vide acer a servi d'
alerte et maintenant je pense que sur
les questions alimentaires on a une
deuxième alerte donc oui oui on va et
c'est souhaitable vers des formes de
garanties de sécurité alimentaire au
moins par zone et par et par région jean
françois loiseau vous êtes vous êtes
d'accord d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de
voir que le ministère de l'économie et
des finances la du tout premier
gouvernement d'elisabeth band s'appelle
maintenant le mystère la souveraineté
aussi bruno le maire on retrouve vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
benjamin coriat on va être plus dans des
zones aujourd'hui d'ailleurs joe biden a
signé aussi un accord de zone avec
l'asie pacifique sur l'europe ça va se
jouer différemment on va être là on
n'est plus dans un contexte de libre
échange absolu bon je pense qu'on ne va
pas passer d'un monde à l'autre
la vraie vie avait entre les deux c'est
dire que y'aura du local et il y aura du
global mais si on prend l'agriculture la
différence de des produits manufacturés
ou de l'aide de la haute technologie qui
peut se fabriquer partout dans le monde
il suffit d'avoir un peu de moyens un
peu de cerveau l'agriculture faut de la
terre je suis désolé il ya en tout cas
peu basique et quand vous êtes dans les
déserts dans certains pays où il ya une
surpopulation
vous n'avez pas suffisamment de denrées
agricoles moi quand je vois que l'inde
non mais parlons-en lan deux minutes
face est un pays assez extraordinaire un
milliard et demi d'habitants l'inde
produit à peu près cent dix millions
tonnes de blé voyait l'afrique a mis la
chine un milliard et demi d'habitants
135 millions de tonnes de blé l'inde 110
millions qui après vous avez la russie
et les grandes plaines partout des
grands pays mais l'inde ne devrait pas
exporter de blé tendre là le sujet de
l'un des exportateurs normalement
entendant mal je parle l'inde a bloqué
sept à huit millions de tonnes
d'exportations mais si rien du tout le
temps qu'il a fait en france a depuis 15
jours nous a déjà enlevé 7 à 8 millions
de tonnes le gros problème de l'inde
sait si jamais il y avait eu un problème
météo de grande ampleur et que plutôt
que de produire 110 millions de tonnes
l'inde produire et 70 millions de tonnes
là je peux vous dire qu'ils ont une
crise alimentaire en inde catastrophique
effectivement la 2è la raison l'a rêvé
de faire ben oui mais sectionnistes avec
ce soit du roi jack il faut que ce soit
fait dans le cas d'une politique avec
des stocks stratégiques et et l'europe
doit reconstituer de recalibrer moi je
dirais une politique agricole et surtout
alimentaires alors on parle de
souveraineté alimentaire je pense qu'il
faut parler de sécurité alimentaire sûre
il faut parler de sécurité alimentaire
de l'émir j'y reviens en s'assurant
aussi du je dirais delà du bon
partenariat avec la proximité et notre
proximité c'est le bassin méditerranéen
et l'afrique c'est vrai que c'est pas la
peine d'aller en asie ou de l'autre côté
de la terre pour vente du blé mais par
contre à deux heures d'avion de paris un
très gros travail mais lorsqu'on parle
de risque de crise alimentaire en tout
cas de flambée des prix en europe
également on se pose quand même des
questions et mai afin de le renverser
une vraie politique agricole commune de
pasdaran et si je peux me permettre et
avec la guerre en ukraine ya une menace
qui pèse aussi sur l'euro ne sont pas
les décideurs les la commission
européenne ne décide pas d'aider des
grandes stratégies heureusement mais
elle a quand même eu un document sur la
table il ya quelques mois qui s'appelle
ferme to fork l'esprit était plutôt bon
transition agricole écologique parce
qu'ils font il faut quand même
décarbonés faut passer à autre chose
mais certaines terres en jachère sait
mais bigre il faut produire plus et moi
le 24 février j'ai lancé une petite
phrase qui fait un peu mal mais je pense
qu'il faut réarmer l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire en france produire
plus ça veut dire renoncer à la jachère
pardonnez moi donc mais il fallait assas
et produire mieux c'est avec beaucoup
moins de carbone fossile moins de chimie
mais beaucoup plus de génétique beaucoup
plus de biologie beaucoup plus
d'agronomie il ya un champ du possible
en france et en europe qui est
remarquable capitalisons sur ces sur ses
possibilités en la nous avons des
possibilités en france et en europe non
mais je conçois que en face aujourd'hui
la critique de farm to fork et de toute
façon n'est pas une panacée tout force
donc c'est la nouvelle stratégie de la
politique agricole bien sûr mais
européenne en fait qui veut direction
mentale à rendre plus verte en voilà
c'est ça c'est à dire que le modèle
productiviste qui s'est développée y
compris dans l'agriculture 1 a produit
toute une série de dégâts et en même
temps et je suis désolé de le dire mais
il faut quand même le rappeler
l'agriculture produit un tiers des gaz
l'agriculture telle qu'elle est
constituée aujourd'hui elle produit un
tiers des gaz à effet de serre donc on
en met donc on avait raison donc on est
dans un cercle vicieux d'une servir
d'espacé autre chose voilà c'est dans
cet endroit clos verte ou non mais il
faut passer à autre chose est doublement
il est passé à une autre agriculture ça
c'est le premier point parce que je n'ai
on peut pas poursuivre dans le modèle
actuel
alors qu'on a les contraintes
climatiques qu'on a et que de toute
façon mais vous avez retrouvé et il faut
passer à autre chose aussi dans la
circulation et les circuits mondiaux
d'alimentation mais en tout cas il a je
vous suis un quand vous dites l'europe
et le bassin méditerranéen
oui absolument c'est évident que c'est
de ce côté là qu'il faut repenser donc
il faut repenser les deux choses à la
fois car une autre agriculture d'autres
circuits karim emile bitar faut être âgé
sur ce qu'on vient de dire ce qu'il
faudrait régionaliser peut-être de
manière plus intelligente les circuits
des changes céréalier dans le bassin
méditerranéen
je pense que oui nous sommes en présence
de tragédies concomitante cette guerre
ukrainienne est venue très vite occulter
les conclusions du rapport du giec qui
étaient très claires et et venus
occulter cette crise alimentaire qui
frappait déjà les pays du moyen orient
donc je pense qu'il est absolument
nécessaire aujourd'hui que les élites
économiques mondiales face leur
autocritique et je pense que le forum de
davos le forum économique mondial bien
qu'il est souvent présentée en france
comme étant le bastion du néolibéralisme
les chantres de l'austérité a déjà
entamé ce processus d'auto critique
ligne rifai a bien résumé le changement
d'état d'esprit qui se déroulait la
barre déjà il ya une vingtaine d'années
en 2003 monsieur schwab avait commencé à
rompre avec les logiques néolibérales
outrancière il s'était
rapproché d'un économiste jeffrey sachs
qui travaillaient sur les rapports
économiques les rapports de
compétitivité et jeffrey sachs est un
exemple de cette transformation il était
dans sa jeunesse très libéral il
préconisait des thérapies de choc pour
l'europe de l'est pour l'amérique latine
est aujourd'hui soutient bernie sanders
aux états unis il plaide pour une
transition écologique pour un green new
deal et c'est l'un des proches de
monsieur schwab et monsieur choix
m'avait déjà dit en 2003 à ma première
visite là-bas qu'il avait compris la
nécessité de rompre avec certaines
pratiques il faut également rappeler que
le fmi a fait lui aussi une autocritique
assez poussée donc il ne faut pas penser
comme on l'a trop souvent le tendance à
le faire aussi bien dans les pays du sud
qu'en france que le fmi et que davos
sont forcément de grands méchants loups
il faut plutôt les accompagner dans ce
processus d'auto critique pour parvenir
un ordre économique mondial plus juste
et almagro écologie pour éviter les
dérives auxquelles nous assistons
aujourd'hui benjamin coriat ce qu'on
n'est pas dans le voeu pieux tout de
même là pour réagir sur ce que dit
karim emile bitar moi j'ai vu aussi que
la patronne du fmi certains ce que
disait line est ce que vient de dire
karim emile bitar elle parle de
régionalisation aussi mais elle dit
attention de ne pas céder aux sirènes de
la fragmentation
géoéconomique qui rendra notre monde
plus pauvres et plus dangereux et donc
écouter navire moi je vais moi je vais
vous rendre des points je vais et je
vais vous faire un aveu
pendant la crise du quotidien est au
coeur de la stupéfaction si je peux dire
on disait beaucoup le monde d'après le
monde d'après un qui sera pas du tout
comme le monde d'avant et puis le monde
d'après il était exactement pareil
exactement pareil moi j'ai été
personnellement catastrophé quand je me
suis retrouvé dans des tables rondes
comme comme celle là avec des
interlocuteurs qui me disait ah oui
le commander l'hôtellerie a perdu 1 8%
mais l'outillage a gagné 3% est donc
vraiment on était absolument comme si
s'était rien passé bon voilà donc ça
rend pessimiste maintenant on a un
deuxième choc qui cette fois va encore
plus profond parce que c'est une
fragmentation géopolitique dont je pense
que sur certains aspects elle est
irréversible vous avez entendu le
discours de ben bon il est pas là pour
rigoler je veux dire la rupture elle et
ils veulent à consommer de manière
définitive et la russie de son côté
comme on l'a vu elle se comporte de
manière extrême rupture des ruptures
avec la russie oui oui et le bail dette
veut la rupture avec la russie et la
russie se comporte de manière
extrêmement brutal donc il ya il ya
quelque chose d'un peu irréversible donc
on peut espérer que cette fois ça va pas
être des voeux pieux c'est à dire qu'il
serait temps de se mettre autour des
tables et de réorganiser les choses un
peu sérieusement jean françois loiseau
mais on al'impression justement cure en
ce qui concerne l'europe reste très
compliquée en france est un vrai débat
aussi sur une agriculture productiviste
contre une anna gray écologie une agri
oui c'est ça à gré écologie agroécologie
pardon donc il ya des oppositions majeur
pour pas sans arrêt parlé d' extrême
pendant 60 ans l'agriculture elle s'est
construite avec l'utilisation de la
chimie nous n'avions pas d'autres
techniques d'ailleurs la santé s'est
construite avec la chimie et les
médicaments étaient tous issus de la
chimie parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre
solution qu'on a besoin de chimie n'ont
pas encore alors de moins en moins mais
toujours comme pour la santé humaine et
donc plus nous avançons plus les
techniques plus les technologies le
travail du sol nous aide à trouver des
solutions - chimie moins carbonées et
c'est tant mieux mais mais attention
s'il n'y avait pas eu la politique
agricole commune pendant 60 ans nous
serions importateurs de blé tendre
venant d'ukraine depuis peut-être 25 ans
s'il n'y avait pas eu cette politique et
pendant le coc vide et quelles activités
ont-elles été résiliente l'agriculture
était totalement résiliente dans les
magasins nous a dit qu'il ya un peu de
pénurie manqué des pâtes pasqua
d'acheter les pâtes par paquets de 20 kg
pas si vous mangez des pas de tous les
jours mais c'était de la folie donc oui
à une agriculture un peu transformé un
peu moins mondialisé mais c'est ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure locale et
globale moins carboné qu'utilisent les
nouvelles techniques moi je pense que
c'est un message très positif pour les
nouvelles générations donc vous restez
optimiste mais bien sûr qu'il faut
l'être et on et moi je suis pas un
combattant d'une multinationale qui veut
aller conquérir le monde ce qui est
intéressant c'est de vous fournir des
produits de qualité sains que vous
puissiez être satisfait de vos
agriculteurs et de vos entreprises
agroalimentaires et puis sans jeter
l'anathème sur tel ou tel secteur de
l'allemagne avec est ce que les prix
alimentaires vont effectivement
inévitablement aujourd'hui être plus
élevé et pas seulement aux gens ont déjà
plus aimés on continue et pas seulement
aujourd'hui c'est à dire dans un tweet
urs et c'est déjà commencé les poitevins
et et la position que ça veut dire que
le consommateur va devoir être plus
sélectifs comme absolument absolument
mais sûr sûr sûr les questions que vous
sous de vie et d'une manière plus
générale ce qu'il faut être optimiste ou
pessimiste
moi j'ai envie de dire j'ai envie de
dire la question et elle n'est pas
vraiment là la question et les kel
bifurcation prends ton alors je suis
d'accord avec vous pas faire ça du jour
au lendemain mais on va désormais bien
c'est malheureusement pas que je dis
bien malheureusement pas possible
presque il va sûrement c'est que ça se
voyait la question bâti de long terme et
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est si
difficile à mettre en place une vraie
transformation bénin parce que c'est ce
qu'on est dans le lointain hier me dire
bien sûr c'est de long terme et ce qui
compte c'est la trajectoire est à dire
'est-ce qu'on bouge la trajectoire ou
pas c'est ça la question parce qu'une
fois qu'on a bouger la trajectoire qu'on
est allé vers des produits
moins - moins carboné
when she mise et nous avons signé rares
après les portes elle se présente de
holly et on les ouvre une par une vous
comprenez donc la question importante
c'est vraiment ça c'est à dire la
conscience qu' on peut pas commencer
comme ça en dessus monsieur est dans un
monde d'après une fois nous sommes sur
cette trajectoire mais vous avez il ya
pas sûr que quand je suis pas sûr que
vous devez vous il ya les produire
jean-françois nous pouvons faut plus
probable la transition agricoles et
alimentaires ce n'est pas moins c'est de
la qualité de la quantité parce qu'il ya
des besoins moi je regrette et le jour
où il ya moins de besoin mais y aura
moins de quantité mais là il ya des
besoins dans un dans un dans une vraie
transformation écologique moi je suis
agriculteur saviez peut-être pas sur ma
ferme j'ai utilisé beaucoup de chimie
pendant 30 ans 20 ans et puis
aujourd'hui j'utilise du désherbage
mécanique des solutions biologiques de
façon m'affranchir de plus en plus vers
deux derniers produits fossiles car tout
le monde n'est peut-être pas comme vous
mais non bien je suis pas les meilleurs
mais moi je pense qu'il faut faire
confiance à la science aux agriculteurs
aux entreprises de l'alimentaire parce
que on oublie de dire mais nous avons 25
à 30 mille entreprises alimentaires
celles qui veulent rester sur les
anciens modèles non non non non non les
avances attend les avances non les avoir
il faut pas seulement fait un mendiant
ça veut dire que bien sûr il faut faire
confiance mais en même temps il y as des
as mais à deux heures d'avion de paris à
des gens alors devenir des inconvénients
de politiques incitatives il ya des
instruments fiscaux il ya des
instruments dead etc ils doivent être
revus moelleux la prime au productivisme
il faut arrêter mais mais le ministre
libanais il m'a téléphoné et c'est comme
le tunisien comme l'égyptien comme le
maroc a ils veulent du blé dès
maintenant et veulent qu'on les priorise
à la moisson prochaine assure donc faut
pas lâcher faut pas lâcher il faut pas
les oublier duction entre le problème en
changeant le modèle mais il faut nous
produire on n'a pas la priorité c est ce
qu on produit plus où est ce qu'on
produit mieux les deux anges de modèle
aux lire différents les deux merci
beaucoup produire différemment merci
beaucoup benjamin coriat d'avoir été
avec tous merci à vous jean françois
loiseau merci
karim emile bitar pardon en direct
avec nous de beyrouth merci à vous
linlin rifai qui étaient avec nous à
davos merci à vous tous deux heures tu
vives restent avec nous soit france 24
[Musique]